that's not the plan
you guys worked with mariba right yeah
mariva is a part of a spillage village
with j.i.d and black and everybody so
yeah Marie was incredible [__] bro she's
such a good writer yeah she's been crazy
on ghost ride yeah she went nuts on that
um shout out to mariba um I was gonna
say uh there is I agree with you on your
uh point about not signing to an artist
but if there was an artist assigned to I
feel like it'd be cool yeah because I
feel like Cole's done such a good job of
like high art Integrity artists yeah and
like he's so out the way that like when
you think of dreamville like you think
of cold but like now I mean dude jid is
a [__] massive Ari Linux is [__]
massive like you know like and I just
feel like he's done such a good job of
like him and uh Eve over there have done
such a good job of building like just a
high high level roster of talent that
isn't necessarily I'm signing you
because you got a [__] hot record you
know I'm signing you because I believe
in you yeah he's so different though J
Cole like I I he's a he's an anomaly
like for sure I mean he's part owner of
the Charlotte Hornets now yeah
Jordan sold the Hornets to a group that
includes J Cole it's [__] incredible
three billion or something crazy like
that
crazy upward Mobility man that's that's
generational well that he's building
when you guys are recording with all the
attention to detail you take
um what is the turnaround process like
like are you guys
does it take a week to finish a song
does it take two weeks to finish this on
just take a night like how does it
usually go
I don't know I feel like it happens
pretty quick it does but at the same
time we'll work on the same group of
songs like we'll bang them out and so
you kind of have like 80 70 of a song
done and then cool let's work on the you
know the guitar part right cleaning up
there for 11 months yeah I'm just
beautifying it you know yeah strings
yeah exactly yeah for sure is this your
guys's first tour since last year's
albums this is the two albums you guys
are touring on right here right yeah
this is our second yeah yeah the uh the
new album is out
um you've how many projects all together
did you guys have now this is our second
album second album okay
um and then you guys uh are starting
towards September yeah
um yeah so go support everything
um how do you guys spell your I mean for
people who don't know spell it out for
everybody people are stupid yeah
blk-o-d-y-s-s-y
yeah Cuban Odyssey coming soon I'm with
it I'm with it oh yeah it did you guys
got bit tired we did yeah yeah what
happened you guys got robbed in the bay
huh OD so they hit the window of the
Sprinter bro my mom had just flew in
yeah
um
yeah we had just come from where the
[__] were we the start before that
yeah probably Seattle Portland yeah or
something like that yeah
Sacramento is what it was actually we
have my mama just wanted to watch us
play my shorty too and we uh
we went into a restaurant for about five
minutes didn't like the way the food and
the service looked so we we left out and
it was already too late five minutes I
went and clean that [__] the quickest
Lake bro quickest [__] ever
suitcase hard drives with our whole
album wanted we have to restart did you
guys have backups yeah [__] oh I was
wearing the same underwear for the rest
of the tour well that's fine we didn't
have no bread you can't go to the store
and buy some new drugs no we didn't have
no bread
maybe that's why the sound guy wasn't
helping you out on tour yeah
I was like this [__] smells like
steak this is before we got Empire
though okay okay
um have you guys ran into Joe Rogan
around town yet out there no no I ran
into Dave Chappelle on the trails
jogging though oh that's [__] great
that was crazy did you talk no no so it
wasn't like George Clinton really like
hey no I'm on the phone like hey I got a
I got an idea for an album you should do
you know maybe because you're
imaginating oh man heavy crazy [__]
day we'll go get the new album
appreciate you guys go check these guys
out on tour uh go follow them online
black Odyssey thanks guys appreciation
thank you brother yes sir